hey guys I'm back in this video we're gonna
talk about the five critical ketosis tips now
I've done a lot of videos in ketosis and some of
you are new some of you have been to my channel
for a long time so I'm going to put some more
links down below so you can get caught up but
these are like really important tips there's a
lot of ways to do it incorrectly and there is
a right way to do it these are the the correct
ways okay so what happens when you do a ketosis
diet it's like taking a diuretic you're gonna
dump a lot of fluid through the body because
when you've been you were burning sugar fuel
you were retaining fluid and now we're cutting
up the sugar you're going to dump a lot of food
this is why some people can lose like 10 pounds
in a week that's not fat that's fluid and with
the fluid comes the elimination of electrolytes
like potassium and magnesium so we must put that
back and a lot of times people need to add more
electrolytes with more fluid so I'm not against
drinking more water especially if you don't overdo
it but we need to put that fluid back make mental
note of this one right here now waste elimination
if you get constipated on this program you have
to handle that because what happens is the toxins
in the fat cell that's stored in there are also
released when you burn this fat so if you don't
have a good elimination system the gallbladder
is working the liver and your get constipated
that is it's going to back up to the thyroid
you know you get the keto rash create a lot
of problems so there's two situations one if
you were constipated before doing this program
and you're still constipated it's okay to take
an herbal laxative in the meantime just to get
things going that's more important than thinking
you're going to be addicted to a laxative or if
you became constipated on this program that means
that either you're you can't digest the kale or
the types of vegetables or the fibers and the
vegetables so switch it up go back to so maybe
some romaine lettuce as compared to some of the
cruciferous and add fermented vegetables and if
you even need maybe a mild laxative tea like a
slippery elm bark smooth move tea go ahead and
do it very very important to get that elimination
going good and I also like to use symptoms that
indication to see what wrong like for example when
you switch from sugar burning to fat burning a lot
of times you might get tired in the transition
that means that your body is utilizing more B
vitamins it's using more sodium so you better
start putting back in the B vitamins if you get
tired or flu-like symptoms and some sea salt
I like to use nutritional yeast okay so that's
a that's very very important now the other thing
is you want to watch watch your fat you know some
people they get this oh they get this program oh
I can start eating tons and tons of fat they start
overdoing it their livers not up to digesting
that their gallbladder is getting blown out
they get right shoulder pain they get the keto
rash all these issues because they're not used
to digesting all this fat and if that happens you
need some gall bladder like purified bile salts
but I would go a little lighter with the fats to
see if you can digest them so your gall bladder
can adapt to that we need sunsets but we don't
want to overdo it okay okay then we get to number
five which is the quality food you just realize
that every single calorie of food that you put
in your body is replacing your body parts okay so
the last thing you want to end up is looking like
a crackhead right yeah so to avoid that to avoid
looking very unhealthy as you lose weight you
want to have grass-fed foods like grass-fed animal
meats things like that you want organic wild-caught
fish pasture-raised eggs okay so if you want to
avoid looking like a crackhead and you want to
look healthy go ahead and put the quality back in
and put your comments below I'll talk to you soon